Trascrizione: Federico Pepe
Revisore: Marco Caresia
«La genetica, cosa può fare?
Selezionare le caratteristiche fisiche
e mentali perfette
in ogni bambino che deve nascere.
[Brusio]
In un futuro non troppo lontano
il nostro DNA determinerà tutto di noi.
Una minuscola goccia di sangue,
di saliva, un capello,
decideranno che lavoro potrai fare,
chi potrai sposare,
quali risultati potrai raggiungere...
In una società in cui il successo
viene determinato dalla genetica
e i cui membri vengono divisi
per gradi di perfezione...
Benvenuti a Gattaca.»
Benvenuti a Gattaca
e benvenuti nel mio genoma:
oggi faremo un salto nel futuro,
passando attraverso questo
film di fantascienza del 1997:
ha quindi poco più di vent'anni.
Un film che oggi è molto vicino
a raccontarci la situazione reale
e qui il pensiero parallelo.
Ricordate che quello... se non l'avete
mai visto o non lo ricordate scaricatelo,
lo trovate sicuramente su YouTube,
e vederete la storia di una società
in cui il destino delle persone,
come avete sentito,
dipende dal proprio patrimonio genetico.
È la storia di un uomo che vuol fare
l'astronauta ma ha problemi genetici
di predisposizione all'infarto per cui,
per questo, viene scartato.
Naturalmente è un film per cui
il messaggio che emerge
è che la volontà dell'uomo
è superiore al suo fisico,
per cui questo uomo,
che dovrebbe morire di infarto,
in realtà riesce a fare l'astronauta
e a raggiungere i suoi obiettivi.
Ora, perché è diventato reale questo film?
Perché le tecnologie che sono presentate
per caratterizzare il patrimonio genetico
degli esseri umani
oggi le abbiamo a disposizione.
Negli ultimi 15 anni c'è stato
un progresso formidabile
nelle tecnologie che solo nel 2001
hanno portato a decodificare
il genoma dell'homo sapiens.
Non era il genoma di una singola persona,
era il genoma di una serie di persone
che doveva rappresentare
il patrimonio genetico dell'umanità.
E solo diversi anni dopo, se guardate
il costo per sequenziare quel genoma
-- tre miliardi di dollari
per sequenziare tre miliardi di basi --
era un costo, un tempo e uno sforzo tale
da rendere impossibile caratterizzare
il patrimonio genetico di ciascuno di noi.
Ma vedete che nel 2014 questo costo
è assolutamente contenuto.
Abbiamo abbattuto la barriera dei 1.000
dollari per cui questa operazione,
caratterizzare e interpretare
il genoma di ciascuno di noi
costa ormai poco più
di una qualsiasi analisi complessa
che possiamo fare in ospedale,
con una grande differenza che,
così come i diamanti,
pure il genoma è per sempre.
Quando l'avete letto una volta,
non cambierà nel corso della vita,
per cui avrete sempre a disposizione
le informazioni che esso contiene.
Se avete guardato... scusate,
sto andando troppo di fretta,
sto cercando di fare un'altra cosa
estremamente laterale:
far dialogare Apple con Microsoft
che sta lì sotto e quindi...
Vedete che questo trend
è abbastanza già conosciuto da noi.
Se guardate quello che è successo
nel campo dell'informatica,
vedete che siamo passati da computer
che costavano 6 milioni di dollari,
pesavano 27 tonnellate e consumavano
150 kiloWatt di energia elettrica
per poter fare pochissime operazioni...
Siamo arrivati ad avere
il personal computer.
E il personal computer, nonostante costi
molto di più di un personal genome,
ha cambiato la nostra vita.
Io ricordo, ero un tesista all'epoca
e sono stato il primo tesista
che ha scritto la propria tesi con un PC
che era appena arrivato
e ricordo che i miei colleghi di qualche
mese più anziani di me, invece,
avevano scritto la loro tesi
con la macchina da scrivere
e ho apprezzato questo impatto formidabile
che questa tecnologia
ha avuto sulla nostra vita.
Molti di voi sono così giovani
che sono nati dopo
che io scrivevo quella tesi col PC,
ma provate a pensare in modo laterale
all'impatto che ha poter salvare
un documento, un'idea, poterla trasferire
su un computer, salvarla,
richiamarla, modificarla, stamparla.
Una cosa fantastica!
Bene, questo tipo di impatto
adesso nella nostra società lo può
avere anche l'analisi del nostro genoma.
Si parla di genoma, questa diapositiva
racconta qualcosa per chi fosse
poco familiare con queste cose.
Voi sapete che abbiamo 46 cromosomi
nelle nostre cellule,
23 che vengono da nostra madre,
23 che vengono da nostro padre.
I cromosi X e Y sono quelli
che determinano il nostro sesso
ma soprattutto i cromosomi
contengono ciò che noi siamo.
Le cellule non fanno altro che prendere
il libretto di istruzioni che è il DNA
che sta lì dentro, leggerlo tutto
e costruire l'organismo;
quindi quello che noi siamo
è esattamente quello che sta scritto
nel nostro manuale delle istruzioni.
Per cui conoscere
questo manuale delle istruzioni
– altro pensiero estremamente laterale –
ci dice quello che noi siamo.
È vero, esiste l'anima,
come Gattaca sottolinea
non c'è un gene per l'anima,
quindi c'è un qualcosa di superiore
a quello che sta scritto
nel nostro libretto delle istruzioni,
però dobbiamo ricordare
che molto di ciò che siamo
e molto di quello che facciamo
in fondo sta scritto lì.
Questo è un libretto che, a volte,
può avere degli errori
per cui conoscere questi errori
permette a noi di riuscire a capire
quali sono, per esempio, le basi genetiche
di numerose malattie terribili
come i tumori o l'infarto
o che sono responsabili di alcune
malattie rare e che determinano,
queste variazioni,
anche le diverse risposte ai farmaci.
Io - altro pensiero laterale - mi aspetto
che, nel giro di pochissimo tempo,
noi andremo in farmacia
e assumeremo un farmaco
che è compatibile
con il nostro patrimonio genetico.
Ci sarà questa vera "medicina
personalizzata" o farmacogenomica,
per cui ad ogni patrimonio genetico,
così come in Gattaca
veniva assegnato un lavoro,
qua verrà assegnato un farmaco
che permette all'individuo
di rispondere in maniera perfetta.
Potremo anche capire quali sono i geni
che permettono di vivere a lungo.
Oggi cominciamo a pensare
che la lunga vita sia dovuta
all'assenza di errori gravi
nel nostro manuale delle istruzioni
cioè noi viviamo a lungo perché non
abbiamo predisposizioni genetiche
che ci portano ad avere malattie gravi
che, purtroppo, accorciano la nostra vita
ma potremmo anche cercare di capire
perché questo signore è ancora vivo
nonostante la quantità di droghe
e alcol che ha assunto.
Come potete vedere in basso a sinistra
questo è il primo genoma sequenziato
per ragioni non mediche,
quindi, veramente, curiosità.
Possiamo anche capire
e cercare in stile Gattaca
quali sono le caratteristiche genetiche
che ci permettono di essere predisposti
per determinati sport.
Io penso che, anche se adesso
hanno scoperto qual è la variante
che permette di fare sport pesanti,
basta guardare il mio fisico per capire
che non serve un test genetico:
io non sarò mai un sollevatore di pesi.
Così come non penso serva un'analisi
genetica per capire se io sono
oppure non sono soddisfatto
del mio stato matrimoniale
perché ho o non ho dei polimorfismi
su questo gene che vedete lì in basso.
Non ho neanche voluto guardare queste cose
sono curiosità, però, che mi permettono
di introdurre il mio genoma e di spiegarvi
le ragioni per cui, in fondo, io mi sono
sequenziato e mi sono decodificato.
Io sono un genetista, non sono un medico.
A Verona da diversi anni sequenziamo
praticamente tutti gli organismi viventi
ultimamente ci è capitato di sequenziare
e decodificare l'uomo.
Da genetista, il primo genoma umano
che ho voluto sequenziare a Verona
è stato, naturalmente,
il mio, per curiosità.
Sono un genetista,
questa è la prima ragione.
La seconda ragione: volevo capire che cosa
si prova a leggere il proprio DNA:
è molto difficile quando,
non essendo medici,
si comincia a lavorare su pazienti
che sono affetti da malattie
e questi pazienti...
spiegano il timore di...
la paura di... leggere
quello che sta scritto
nel proprio patrimonio genetico.
Dicono: "È facile
che tu legga il mio genoma,
ma hai provato a leggere il tuo?"
Ecco, io ho provato a rispondere
a questa domanda;
ho provato a leggere il mio genoma
e ho cercato di capire la difficoltà
con la quale pure io, genetista,
approcciavo informazioni
che potevano essere difficili da accettare
come una predisposizione
ad alcune malattie genetiche hanno valori
di insorgenza estremamente elevati
per cui trovare alcune varianti
significa avere, prima o poi,
sicuramente lo sviluppo
di quella malattia.
La terza ragione è che per la privacy,
per fortuna, non possiamo mostrare
i dati degli altri per cui, per esempio,
in un'occasione come questa,
non avrei potuto mostrare alcun genoma
se non il mio appunto per queste ragioni
essendo il mio, posso farci
quello che voglio e allora...
ho il mio genoma su questo iPad,
tutto qua dentro,
è protetto per la mia privacy
con una password
che non riuscite a leggere.
(Risate)
Signore e signori,
benvenuti nel mio genoma.
Immaginate di essere su Google Maps,
immaginate di essere
con il livello di zoom minore
per cui vedete il globo terrestre.
Qua vedete i miei cromosomi,
vedete tutti i miei autosomi
che sono i cromosomi
non sessuali più l'X e l'Y.
Ora proviamo a fare come su Google
e proviamo a zoomare all'interno
e quindi prendiamo, ad esempio,
il mio cromosoma numero 1.
Ci entriamo, adesso il sistema è ancora
un po' lento, ma vi fa vedere
che ci sono, lo vedete a destra,
2.500 istruzioni su questo cromosoma.
Istruzioni che hanno a che fare
con diverse condizioni
che potete vedere a sinistra.
Purtroppo la prima cosa
che appare è l'alcolismo.
Io sono piacentino, ero astemio,
sono arrivato a Verona...
penso che sia una vera interazione
genotipo-ambiente.
In questo caso, mi sono innamorato
del vino. (Applausi)
Adesso vi faccio vedere cosa posso fare
per esempio posso vedere
– e questa è una cosa incredibile –
ho una mutazione
per cui se assumo un anti-depressivo
vado in depressione più di quanto
fa una persona normale.
E questo vi spiega l'importanza
di poter un giorno associare
il farmaco al patrimonio genetico.
Ma come vi dicevo, così come Google
io posso entrare nel mio cromosoma
e cominciare ad allargare
e quindi zoomo, zoomo,
sono a livello di stato,
poi posso arrivare a livello di città,
per poi arrivare, alla fine...
vedete sono partito
da 250 milioni di basi,
adesso sono a 135 mila
(lo vedete in basso a sinistra)
allargo, allargo, vedo le varianti...
queste barre viola che vedete
sono le varianti rispetto al genoma
di riferimento quindi sono le cose
che caratterizzano me rispetto a voi e,
ad un certo punto, il sistema va in stallo
perché deve cambiare database.
Allarga ancora, allarga ancora... ecco.
Io adesso sto leggendo,
come se fossi su Google Maps
e vedessi le strade
con il nome della strada,
io qua sto leggendo il mio DNA
e sotto vedete "Reference" che è
il genoma di riferimento
e quello sopra il "Current Genome"
è il mio genoma.
Per cui io vedo che sono praticamente
uguale al genoma di riferimento,
qua c'è una variante, che è una variante
associata appunto a questa diversa
risposta all'anti-depressivo che mi porta,
appunto, ad andare in depressione.
Ma adesso vi faccio vedere la cosa
più difficile che è stata, per me,
guardare; andare a vedere le malattie
di cui ho predisposizioni genetiche.
Ne ho diverse ma, devo dire, sono,
almeno per quello che conosciamo oggi,
siamo agli inizi, ancora di una nuova era
che è quella di comprendere
cosa sta scritto nel nostro genoma
per cui le informazioni che abbiamo
sono ancora estremamente limitate,
però cominciamo ad averle...
Vedete ho predisposizione ad alcune
malattie, niente di gravissimo.
Se non fosse che morirò un giorno
improvvisamente, spero di notte,
in un letto, perché ho una predisposizione
genetica per la sindrome del QT lungo,
che è un difetto nella ripolarizzazione
del cuore dopo il battito
che determina la morte improvvisa.
È una delle cause per cui,
improvvisamente,
ogni tanto lo sentite,
i calciatori o atleti
che stanno svolgendo la loro attività,
si accasciano al suolo e muoiono.
Ora, non entro nei dettagli
ma se guardate su Google News
troverete nella seconda notizia,
adesso è diventata la quarta,
cambia: siamo on-line, giusto?
È un sistema estremamente dinamico
per cui è già cambiato...
la quarta notizia: un ragazzo di 21 anni,
il padre entra in camera sua al mattino
e lo trova morto: non si erano accorti
che aveva questa predisposizione genetica
che è stata osservata in questo caso
solo post-mortem.
Questa mia "malattia",
ancora io non la sviluppo,
anche essere su questo palco porta
all'accelerazione del battito.
Una persona che soffre di questa sindrome
dovrebbe bloccare qualsiasi emozione
quindi dovrei prendere betabloccanti;
dovrei stare a casa sempre,
evitare che i colleghi e gli amici,
la moglie, la famiglia
mi faccia arrabbiare e invece ho una vita
estremamente stressante.
Sono ancora vivo,
non entro nei dettagli di questa cosa,
ma voglio farvi vedere una cosa.
La settimana scorsa,
sapendo di venire qui,
ho convinto un collega medico
qui dell'ospedale di Borgo Roma
a sottopormi all'esame,
a farmi l'elettrocardiogramma
e dirmi se poteva dimostrare clinicamente
quello che la genetica mi diceva
cioè che io soffro della sindrome
del QT lungo.
La sindrome del QT lungo, vedete,
è lo spazio che passa tra Q e T
quando questo spazio temporale
è superiore a un certo valore
vuol dire che il cuore ha problemi
e praticamente sono problemi elettrici:
viene a mancare il segnale.
Improvvisamente il segnale
non è sufficiente
e il cuore si ferma e la persona,
in assenza di un defibrillatore,
è destinata a morire.
Il valore che io ho è 504.
Questo medico, sorpreso e preoccupato,
mi ha detto: "I maschi hanno un valore
generalmente sotto i 440
e le femmine sotto i 460,
non consideriamo il valore del QT
pericoloso quando è sotto i 480.
Sopra i 480 bisogna
che proseguiamo con le analisi
e, forse, dovrai arrivare a..."
A fare quello
che ha fatto l'astronauta in Gattaca.
A ingannare i medici,
nascondendo loro le informazioni genetiche
e vivendo la mia vita convinto
che il mio spirito sia comunque superiore
a quello che sta scritto
nel mio patrimonio genetico.
Da genetista, però, devo ricordare
che questa è la genetica:
è così che funziona...
speriamo Gattaca abbia avuto ragione.
Grazie.
(Applausi)